lamia l'université de barre des 7
intéresse de chanter a capella nous
désole chez même pas champion
souvent tu t'appelles et met la balle
elle finit là bas les histoires que des
crevettes dans votre genre je fasse pas
dans mon dos
suisses et chanteuse tu doit auditionner
pour les vélos nous répéterons et je
compte sur vous pour travailler le
cardio en plus longues
moi je suis dispensé cardio grèce que tu
fabriques fait la course horizontale
voici la liste de toutes les chansons
que nous avons présenté sur scène on n'a
même pas eu de cession vous êtes super
nul au les petites chéries n'oubliez pas
le rendez vous chez la manucure nous ces
unions gays les trouva dur ne nous
respecte pas on devrait prendre des
risques assurés ça suffit pas vous
préparer pour le match à fond ne suffit
pas à les compter
d'intégrer
on va remix élévé là vous êtes parti
pour une grosse ratatiner vous allez en
avoir les tétons pour enfoncer
girlz il faudrait qu'on s'embrasse j'ai
le sentiment des fois que je peux y
aller sur les en-têtes mais ensuite je
dis
mauvaise idée